[Music]
foreign
as I've mentioned we have 70 plus
musicians who are about to Grace our
stage tonight and yes yes and because we
have so many with us I want to take a
special make a special thanks on behalf
of our executive director and CEO and
our dedicated and remarkable board I
want to thank our staff
um thank you staff thank you the team
Wallace team for making all of this
happen in one afternoon and what an
exciting rehearsal it was so excited and
thank you Josh and your entire team of
course thank you koi um I'm Josh Welsh
president of film independent and I just
want to say thank you
give it up for film independent we we
love doing events here at the Wallace
this is our home away from home we do
really special programming here we do
live reads of classic screenplays we do
evenings with extended conversations
with notable talent and of course Bring
the Noise which is if you haven't been
to a Bring the Noise before it's a mix
of film conversation and live music and
it can take many different forms and
tonight we have an incredibly special
evening I'm so excited for this we've
never done anything remotely like this
we're so honored to have uh Mary
McCartney here talking about her
beautiful new film if these walls could
sing
she will be in conversation with Morgan
Neville a longtime friend of film
independent and a great filmmaker
and then of course uh conductor Mark
Graham is going to lead a 72-person
Orchestra in music that was recorded at
Abbey Road so very special night
um I want to add just a couple thank
yous I want to thank the hfpa for being
a founding of a presenting sponsor of
film independent presents thank you so
much I want to yes give it up
and I I want to give a shout out to
Sandra cunio who I know is here tonight
Sandra you are an angel
um I also want to thank Disney Original
documentaries for for making this
possible
um and I want to thank the film
independent staff we could not do this
without a lot of support and creativity
and um I want to thank the programming
and events team at film independent led
by the one and only Rachel bloemer
so um
with that it is my great honor to
introduce a filmmaker I've already
mentioned in my name but he's the
director of 20 Feet from Stardom best of
enemies Yo-Yo Ma and the Silk Road
Ensemble so many beautiful films
um please welcome the one and only
Morgan Neville
um my first memories of Abbey Road we
lived nearby and
um it's literally just going around and
visiting my mom and dad when they were
recording and my first memories are
really are um of the reception area that
used to just have all of these color
pictures of all the different bands that
had been there particularly one of Kate
Bush was really striking so you know
they were very early memories and then
like at the beginning of the of the
documentary it only went on at the very
end we kind of introduced it by saying
you know my history goes way back so
when I was asked to direct the
documentary I contacted the woman who
runs my mum's photo archive and said do
you have any pictures
of me at Abbey Road and she immediately
texted me back like this baby picture of
like three months old in the corner so
it's kind of crazy so you were dead I'd
love to make this film yeah and the
thing is it was brilliant because I
apart from that I didn't and then when I
was older and I was working I used to go
to Abbey Road for work and I became
friends with Ken Townsend the manager
and the people that actually work there
so that's why I really had my affection
for this the people the staff that you
know so I had those two elements but I
didn't know anything about the history
of it you know all of that was learned
in making the documentary and it's all
in the film so why don't we watch our
first clip and then we'll talk some more
that is such a great story well we were
so lucky to find that interview with
Shirley Bassey that I mean that scene
that was such a sort of famous story
within Abbey Road that people would tell
me about but we had absolutely nothing
to illustrate it
which is with a lot of the stories you
understand as a documentary filmmaker
it's like how do you illustrate a story
if you can't then it can't go into the
documentary
well it's you know one of the challenges
of making a film about recording and I
I've done it too which is most of this
happens in rooms with no cameras often
in the middle of the night and how do
you make this come alive and you do so
many interesting things visually and
otherwise an incredible archive but how
did you face the challenge of trying to
make put us into scenes like this so we
actually feel like we're there
um the interviews we relied heavily on
the interviews because for instance we
knew from with the thing that we really
had that was great was all of the
recording session sheets and um there
was a Naomi who had gone through all of
them so she brought it to us and said
look Jimmy Page you can see that he was
actually a session musician on
Goldfinger and then he agreed to be
interviewed bless you whoever sneezed
there
um but he agreed to be interviewed but
then as you'll know like I interviewed
several people and I sort of asked them
something thinking they're going to tell
me about this and that will help me and
a lot of the times people like I can't
really remember it or it wasn't the
story that you have been told over the
years that happened a few times with
other stories I'd heard about so I was
like really hoping that Jimmy Page
remembered it well and that it was what
it had become as the folklore so he was
brilliant and so because he was told
that story so well
um and then I found my my archive has
found that one really great interview
with Shirley Bassey I mean it's just
those two stories and then some filming
in the studio that's it I mean I I love
that
um do you have Jimmy Page telling that
story talking about being a session
musician you also have Elton John in the
film talking about being a session
musician at Abbey Road I mean it's just
such a great way of
seeing these musicians differently but
also now hearing these songs differently
like I don't think I'm going to listen
to these songs the same way ever again
yeah I think also what's good because
you and I were sort of touching on it
before we came on stage was interesting
is
um I didn't really know a lot of it
before I started researching and and I
didn't realize that the recording system
in the beginning was three hour sessions
the band had to arrive rehearsed and
ready the producer told them what to do
and then it was done so that was how
most everybody started in the early 60s
so Elton John as Reginald Dwight will
have been like this jobbing session
musician and then it sort of grew and
grew and grew so when I interviewed him
it was like having him back being a kid
like you could see I think you can see
in the interview he goes back you can
sort of see the way he's sitting that it
he and being in Abu doing the interview
it feels like it really took him back so
it feels much more emotional I think as
an interview I mean I'm sure that was an
experience you had again and again
because it seems like you interviewed
almost everybody in in the studio or
many of the people in the studio just
that experience of them being back I
mean you see people in the film reacting
to being back there and it's part of
what people react to when they make
music there the kind of the what the
space conjures in you you know the the
ghosts whatever you want to talk about
that that space has and it's both
something that is
um
powerful but it's also difficult to
describe and you as a documentary
filmmaker in this case have to kind of
try and explain what it is about this
building that has this power and so how
did you approach a problem like that
um it felt like first of all I just said
yes to do you know first I toyed with
whether I should take on the documentary
and then once I committed to it I kind
of committed to it without a very clear
plan it was sort of like a lot of the
things I do I say yes and then close my
eyes and just jump in so
um I I signed up for the job and then
spent a lot of time researching and sort
of sitting writing out exactly what
happened when it opened what it you know
going through what the building was
before looking at the plans looking at
everybody that had recorded there and
from there it grew and
um the main thing that concerned me at
the beginning was I wasn't sure if I was
going to be able to do justice to
bringing the emotion of going into the
studio so a lot of the facts I was
learning were really interesting facts
but um but I was like this or this is
like oh that's interesting that's
interesting but actually I wanted people
to feel that emotion and and the other
thing is I've grown up watching you know
the beginning of the documentary I start
on the zebra Crossing because there's
always people there and it means so much
to them that's kind of who I was making
it for in a way sort of bringing you
inside the studio yeah well and of
course I mean there's a lot of emotion
in the film and a lot of it
comes from the music too I mean that's
what music does that's the the gift as
being documentary filmmakers that work
with music you know and and you as you
pointed out the interviews like luckily
because I didn't have anybody nobody had
agreed to say I could have signed up and
then everyone's like oh thanks nice idea
but no but luckily I think because
everyone has such fond feelings and
emotion for Abbey Road pretty much
everybody agreed some people took a bit
more persuading than others but who who
need a more persuading Roger Waters gave
me the runaround for a long time
no I mean I was looking okay just for
those of you who haven't seen it
um because I was just it's an amazing
lineup of people in the film I mean John
Williams Elton John Ringo your father
uh Jimmy Page Dave Gilmore Roger Waters
not together uh Liam and Noel Gallagher
not together
Nick Mason Cliff Richards
um George Lucas now Rogers I mean it
goes on and on you know it's it's uh
you know a wealth of amazing
figures but that speaks to what what the
space is too
you know and and what
um also struck me is unlike
other documentaries or stories about
other Studios
you know we're talking about Muscle
Shoals or Sound City or these other
places
um that where people gather to make
music I was thinking about it I mean
Abby Road or Emi Studios as it was first
known was a purpose-built studio the
first in the world right in 1931 I think
I learned in the film
um
but it's the only Studio I could think
of that really
did all kinds of music so uh lots of
classical lots of orchestral
I mean some of my favorite footage in
the film is uh Jacqueline Dupree
is just an incredible you know
incredible footage of her
um playing cello so you not only have to
balance time and stories but you have to
balance genres and tone and pace and all
these things so how how was that
challenge for you um
think at first I sort of wanted I had a
hist of people and songs I wanted to put
in and then
um I realized that it would just be too
much and too eclectic and again to bring
in the emotion it's sort of like you
need fewer people telling more of the
story and and as I I spent a good amount
of time researching at the beginning
which sort of
was very helpful because it's sort of
was like a classical how are we going to
do this how we all these different
sections and I kind of wanted it
chronologically sort of planned out but
also it dips around into different
themes
um but then there were these sort of
serendipitous moments where we were like
right
and Edward Elgar opened the studio 1931
and then it was like okay then I
realized Jacqueline I found out
Jacqueline Dupre had recorded the Elgar
concerto there and she's like I'd always
loved her
her as a musician as an artist and her
story is very emotional as well and very
you know as we found great interviews
with her and then I found out that sheku
who's my modern interview had also
performed Edward he'd recorded Edward
algarcello concerto there and he was
basically influenced by Jacqueline
Duprey to become a cellist and he has a
very similar way in which he plays it
really kind of gets you
right you know right there so I mean
that's the thing I mean I it's the first
documentary I've made but it's sort of
like you kind of hope for the best and
then when you get those things you're
like okay this is gonna it's coming
together those are very good days
um so another thing I didn't really
realize is what
um Dire Straits the studio was in in the
late 70s financially
because bands like Dire Straits weren't
playing there and recording there uh
sorry
um
so uh so what saved the studio
Hollywood right yeah so Ken Townsend was
the manager who is like Ken Townsend is
kind of Abbey Road because before he
became manager it was very kind of
um authoritarian and you know he made it
he told me he was like he likes cricket
and and so he wanted it to be like a
team so he sort of gave delegated people
to have control in different departments
and really transformed the way it's run
and it has that same kind of system now
that he he put into place so um he found
out basically Studio One is the huge
orchestral
um studio and it's really big and it
wasn't really being booked because
pretty much all of the classical
recordings have been done and then
they've been done again for CD and it
just really was laying empty a lot of
the time and um he had his ear to the
ground and found out that the recording
studio outside London had lost its lease
so he got in touch with the producer
that was doing the film scores and said
let's do a deal I think we're going to
see a film clipped it yeah tells part of
the story so let's run the next clip
tell it much better than I would no
foreign
it feels like you have some thought
after watching that clip it was just how
excited I was after the John Williams
interview because if it had if he hadn't
been so eloquent about talking about the
space I probably would have needed to do
several other interviews but literally
we did that one interview and it was
like
between him and George Lucas it was sort
of like we were done which was
great because it sort of again it sort
of just makes the the sections neater
but also that was when um the premiere
for the documentary was that Abbey Road
they did for the first time at Premier
Abbey Road they put in like speakers and
a sound system and the screen and we sat
on the orchestral chairs but it was that
was so exciting watching that bit when
he's sort of the film of John Williams
conducting in Studio One and we were
sitting in Studio One watching it was
pretty you know pinch yourself moment
yeah that's pretty pretty special
um so a story like this obviously the
story of the studio continues
so how do you think about ending a film
like this because the film has a very
powerful ending but how did you craft
that have what went into it
um yeah that's the thing I wanted early
on I was sort of thinking about
um how to end it because I wanted it to
have a really strong ending and for you
to have that real feeling at the end
like sort of that you know when you walk
out of somewhere and you're like I want
to do something I want to so um uh we I
found a recording of Celeste singing
hear my voice and I've worked with her a
couple of times before taking her
portraits because I'm a poor you know
really this is the first documentary
I've directed so I really used a lot of
my techniques and portrait photography
sort of came into play a lot with the
interviews but I found that
um piece really strong piece of her
singing hear my voice in Abbey Road
Studio 2 and I interviewed her as well
and then we kind of sum up with some
very strong sort of one-liners from
people so you sort of finish feeling
really
in love with Abby Wright
I want to ask you because you just
alluded to it as a photographer and
somebody who's done a lot of portraiture
how did that play into how you both made
the film shot the film and did the
interviews because I'm always interested
in what people bring in their own
experience to to their filmmaking I
think
what the biggest help was
um being prepared and sort of creating
knowing that the way that I like to do
portraits is to create an area that I
know someone's going to feel comfortable
in
so that when they come in they're not
like oh why you know they're not sort of
distracted by something so I think that
was the most helpful thing though from
having all that experience I kind of had
it all set up I was really well
researched well prepared but then a lot
of it then you sort of nicely lit
comfortable but then the rest is down to
the kind of chemistry of how you get
along and how that conversation that's
the exciting bit
absolutely
obviously part of this is part of your
father's story too
how how did you think about
crafting that part of the story you know
how much did you ask for his input or
did you not ask for his input in terms
of thinking about what parts of that
history you wanted to tell he was
helpful with um giving me little nuggets
of information like he when I I told him
I I was directing the documentary and he
would sort of say things like how you
know how things you know he was telling
me about how the Mrs Mills piano would
just be in the corner and you know Abby
wrote today still there are like tape
machines in the hallway Mrs Mills piano
which was on Lady Madonna
um and all and you know in a way I was
even thinking is that why the Beatles
ended up using so many orchestral pieces
on their recordings probably because of
Studio One and seeing you know symphonic
pianos so you know he helped pierce it
all together
just something else I want to comment on
is I mean maybe it's in part because
you're a photographer
but visually you managed to make it
both beautiful but also kind of come
alive in a way and I'm just wondering
I'm also I think I love the graphics in
the film too but I think I'm sure a lot
of thought went into all of that yeah in
terms of how to craft them I just wanted
it to be really visually interesting to
the viewer so I was like look we'll do
an interview but like let's not just
have talking head interviews that was
sort of like originally I wouldn't have
wanted any talking head interviews it
would have been all footage and
um but there just wasn't that much
footage but then
um I filmed it
um
my picture lagged but I'm forgetting
what's the anamorphic and and with
anamorphic lenses so it sort of has this
letterbox technique so then I was really
excited we kind of used the um the stock
footage with like three screens but then
I did get a phone call from my producer
just
telling me I was burning all the money
on the budget on the clearance form so
he was like stop doing that because I
it's the first time I'd done it so I was
blissfully unaware
but so you know I have film you know the
interviews it's sort of about creating
layers and textures and photographs so I
just want it to be something that sort
of really
gets the viewer interested
so are you going to make another
documentary yeah definitely you enjoyed
the experience enough and I did because
um it was the the team that I had were
really great to work with and we all
worked really hard but we all got on
really well and and it was a it's quite
a small team
um but we we were on the whole project
the whole time together so and I had my
editor as a drama editor so I think that
really helps that he and I kind of could
debate on you know we didn't have it
wasn't like it's not like a typical
music documentary edit which is
something I was really wanting to avoid
yeah there's some great editing he's a
brilliant editor
um I think it's about time for the the
other event tonight which you know an
incredible treat
um that we are going to have a chance to
listen to some of the music some of the
scores some of the songs made famous and
recorded at Abbey Road and we have some
people here to make it all come true so
amazing why don't we uh thank you so
much Mary for doing this
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
no no on course
[Laughter]
[Applause]
um no encourse prepared that's it from
us it's been a pleasure to play this
stuff for you tonight uh congratulations
on the success of such a great film
thanks for coming see you next time
thank you good night
[Laughter]